it's et's social study what the stars  are posting online for really excited  about Amy Schumer's boyfriend bin henna  SH is her biggest fan after Amy released  her new Netflix comedy special her boat  took to social media to gush about his  girlfriend he posted this pic of the  comedian in a swimsuit writing so proud  of this babe  then there's Nicki Minaj channeling  Rapunzel as she stepped out for Paris  Fashion Week to attend the V Magazine  party well we can't take our eyes off  the Anaconda rapper sporting insanely  long extensions that reach her ankles  [Music]  and pregnant Beyonce joins Kelly Rowland  and her mom Tina to celebrate her  stepdad Richard Lawson  70th birthday then there's Kendra  Wilkinson baskets sharing this sultry  shot and sounding up on the haters quote  I left the Playboy world almost ten  years ago and have moved on in my life  push the haters out  you